you know i love theory crafting i love
just working up different theories and
stuff like that
i try not to read other theories because
i'd like to come up with my own but
in this day and age is kind of
unavoidable so the basis behind what
we're going to talk about here
is predicated on the theory that was not
thought up by me i want to specify that
i don't really steal
other people's theories but it was not
thought up by me instead it was thought
of by a combination of i assume reddit
users i
read it in an article one of the things
that some of you guys pointed out is
that lady loki in the tv show
is not actually lady loki right based on
the end credits of the spanish version
of the loki tv show that it's basically
sylvia or some people are calling her
enchantress that's fine if it's
enchantress that's cool i don't really
think it makes much of a difference i
mean
enchantress was never really interesting
to me in a lot of ways she was kind of
like the asgardian version of aphrodite
from the greek mythology
especially when you go and you look at
like marvel ruins where she basically
became like an adult film star
but it's one of those things where it's
it's like i mean it's it's cool right it
doesn't really
drive a lot of interest in my book but
what is really cool
is that there's a theory floating out
there that this chick right silvia
lady loki enchantress whatever you want
to call her we'll use her name
interchangeably over the course of the
video
that she is a variant
but was formerly a member of the time
variance authority
that's a cool theory so then i started
thinking about that right i was like
what if that really is the case like
what if
she really is a former member of the tda
one of the things that this theory
explains is why it is that she knows the
tactics and strategies of the tva how it
is she's able to get around
circumvent how she can use reset
chargers that she looks like a member of
the tva who basically went rogue but the
question for that is
why why would a member of the tva go
rogue and then launch a bunch of reset
chargers into the time stream
with the intention of spawning a whole
litany of alternate realities
let's take a break from loki for a
second and let's go look at marvel
comics and let's talk about a group
called the exiles so the exiles were a
really really cool concept in terms of
how they were created the idea
is that you had a group called the time
brokers or the time breakers whatever
you want to call them the whole point
was that the multiverse was kind of on
this brink of collapse
and a group needed to be formed that
could kind of fix these different
universes the reality is a really
thin plot but it basically gave us some
cool stories where you saw this kind of
multiversal team
that was composed of different members
from alternate universes and the roster
would change all the time right it would
shift up
all the time so you would have one story
arc where you might have like the x-man
wolverine from an alternate reality and
then like he might die
so then he'll be replaced with like
magneto from from a different reality
and just all that kind of stuff right
just kind of going on and on and on and
on but nonetheless
one of the cool things that goes on here
is that when it comes to the
exiles their main enemy was a guy by the
name of
hyperion now i do want to say i don't
think hyperion is going to have a role
in loki but the whole gist behind this
is hyperion was a member of the team
and it actually duped them at the same
time because they were taking their
orders at one point by a guy called the
time broker
not really sure who he was until you
found out that it was basically hyperion
so they were heroes who were going on
these exceedingly dangerous missions
getting their orders from a future
version of a guy
who basically led to the destruction of
all life on his own earth
and so because of that it introduced
this notion of
a heroic team doing bad things not
realizing that they're doing bad things
because
they don't know the person giving them
their orders is a bad guy
they think they're just doing what
they're supposed to be doing which kind
of makes sense right i mean how
extensive could any one person's
knowledge
of every reality in an infinitely
expanding multiverse
possibly be and so the more i started
thinking about that the more i was like
okay let's apply that to
lady loki enchantress silvia whatever
let's apply that to her character and
let's see if we can't
extrapolate this out so if we know that
she's a rogue agent then the question
becomes what letter to becoming a rogue
agent well let's look at the tva for a
second
another theory floating around out there
is that tva agents are basically
variants from alternate universes
i'm not entirely sure i agree with that
just because of the fact that there's so
many
tva agents out there the amount of time
and effort
needed to grab all those people from
alternate realities
bring them in and then as the theory
states wipe their minds
give them new memories convince them
that the time keepers are right and then
have them reach their current form would
be colossal right that's a massive
undertaking unless you have giant groups
of people who are doing it i don't know
exactly what's going on with the tva i
will say
i think they're largely just created
right they're just kind of made
and they exist and that's really it i
think the tva is exactly what you see i
don't really think there's a whole lot
of of uh mystery and intrigue going on
there
but it does kind of ask questions about
like owen wilson's character and his
love of a jet ski one of the things that
theory had postulated was
that because owen wilson loves jet skis
which is uncharacteristic for a tva
agent that in turn he was at one point a
variant
who had something to do with jet skis i
don't know maybe he was a jet ski
salesman and that when his mind was
wiped and he was positioned in the tva
and then told you've always been here
that over time those memories are
basically starting to come back and
they're coming back in the form of his
love of particular things which will
ultimately coalesce in him realizing
who he was and how it all works but
wrapping back around to this
assuming that the tva are just kind of
created and there really isn't a whole
lot going on there that still kind of
begs the question of what's going on
with this lady loki enchantress check
here's my thought on this and i want to
run this by you
and see what you all think so let's say
that we look at this animation
that was given to loki by miss minutes
which looks us already
and it's predicated on the actions of
the timekeepers who
seem pretty suspicious because like
screenrant pointed out in their tweets
and in their their various articles
that for a group that has such a
fine-tuned control
or direction that the universe needs to
go in you never see them
and like any authority figure you would
think they would be out there
dictating what needs to happen telling
people how stuff has to unfold
instead all you get is the judge the
judge is i operate on their behalf i
basically give instructions to the tva
based on what it is that they want to
have done i mean
maybe they're sending her messages by
way of carrier pigeons
i have no idea but the important thing
is she supposedly does what the
timekeepers tell her to
and that's all we really get here but
let's say that's not the case
let's say that one of two possibilities
is going on here one
the timekeepers are dead right they've
been dead for a long long time
the multiversal war that happened which
i believe actually did take place
saw the timekeepers ultimately destroyed
and defeated and the victor of the
multiversal war
has been pretending the timekeepers was
actually alive putting forward this
narrative that the timekeepers destroyed
whoever this
victor happens to be and now the
timekeepers are the ones that are quote
unquote giving orders
when in reality it's that bad guy that
particular victor in this instance i'd
say maybe immortus an alternate reality
persona of king the conqueror
i don't really know we know we're going
to see kang and ant-man 3 he's rumored
to be in loki but i'm just kind of using
the victor as just kind of some
ambiguous name of whoever that person
happens to be
no real definition there but the
important thing is he's secretly or
she's secretly operating behind the
scenes
pulling the strings and nobody in the
tva knows the tva believes they're
getting their orders from the
timekeepers
and much like the judge stated the
timekeepers are exceedingly busy trying
to make sure the timeline stays intact
which makes sense that's no easy task
right it's not a red button that you
push every 10 minutes it takes a lot of
work to kind of keep that stuff going
the other alternative here
is that the timekeepers were the ones
who started the multiversal war
that the multiverse was really just a
whole bunch of universes that all
existed in harmony with each other maybe
there was some kind of conflict between
universes but that's just the natural
order of things
that universes die and universes are
born and that's just the cycle of how
the multiverse functions
but the time keepers wanted control the
time keepers
wanted to be the ones to run the show
they wanted to be this kind of absolute
authority maybe they were narcissists
maybe
they believed they should just have that
rightful role whatever their logic
happened to be
and so they ultimately incited a war or
started going through
and conquering all these different
universes and that the multiversal war
was not a war between the time keepers
and somebody like king the conqueror
instead it was a war between the time
keepers and those who were resisting
being conquered
whole realities that were actually
fighting back against them in the same
way that like the rebel alliance fought
the empire in
star wars the timekeepers ultimately
proved to be successful
they overcame that rebel faction or
those universes and they basically
wiped them all out of existence using
some kind of doomsday weapon or maybe
that's why they developed reset charges
or something along those lines and then
now the time keepers are the ones
running the show but regardless of what
situation we go with what scenario
whether it's a war between the time
keepers and kang
or it's just the time keepers conquering
the multiverse that this character lady
loki enchantress what have you
figured out what was going on she
realized what was actually happening
here that the timekeepers
are bad guys or the timekeepers are not
alive and there's some guy running
behind the scenes
that's controlling everything but
regardless she's doing what she can
to basically take pot shots and defeat
them that in reality
she's a good guy and that's one of the
things that looks kind of weird because
the only thing that we really know about
her
is what the tva has told loki and by
extension
told us it's a variant version of loki
that's going across the multiverse and
killing different members of the tva and
stealing their reset chargers but if you
look at the situation for what it is it
doesn't look as though this individual
takes satisfaction
in killing the members of the tva i
wouldn't go as far as to say that she's
crying over it
or begging them to like just let her
take the reset chargers but
the goal is the reset charger and we
know the tva won't give that up without
a fight right we saw that in the initial
conflict with loki when he was trying to
get his hands on a reset charger
trying to control his time collar so
it's one of those things where they keep
that under lock and key
the only way to get it is to actually
kill them and then take it
but regardless it may be one of these
things where because she's basically a
good guy
she's trying to undo everything or she's
trying to bring the multiverse back
create what are in effect allies and
then in turn
get rid of whoever this person happens
to be that's running the tva secretly
whether it's the time keepers themselves
who are lying to everybody in the tva
or some mysterious figure who's
operating behind the scenes and that
we'll learn
as time goes on not everything's what it
seems i don't think the tva
are really allies in this i don't really
think the tva
the judge is secretly working alongside
this enemy and that in turn
she's gonna receive some increased level
of power or whatever the case happens to
be
i think the tva really has no idea
what's going on and the tva is just
following orders
it could also be the judge really is the
one behind the scenes pulling the
strings right i mean
none of us suspected agatha harkness and
it turned out to be her in one division
that would be the simplest thing
that the judge is just conning everybody
but this also presents a lot of other
possibilities
say for example this lady loki
enchantress chick survives
that because she's a good guy she
doesn't die she allies herself with loki
then they end up pairing up with doctor
strange during multiverse of madness
because a lot of you guys seem to have
pointed out
her actions in the loki tv show may very
well give birth to the multiverse of
madness that we see in doctor strange
too
and so if you have lady loki and then
you've got loki and then you've got
doctor strange
now you got a team and so there's a lot
of possibilities that you can do with
these particular things
and so if that's the case that segues
perfectly into doctor strange too
it gives us that plot i don't really
know how wanda would tie into it it may
be one of these things where's just
people taking completely separate
avenues that all kind of end up in the
same place that wanda has
nothing to do with the time variance
authority or the time keepers or
potentially the secret individual who's
operating behind the scenes controlling
the tva
instead she's just on a mission for her
kids and that the voices of her kids
that she heard which was most likely
manipulation by somebody else
is just them trying to get out of
whatever prison they happen to be in
because the multiverse is in such a
state of disarray and it's the perfect
time to do it
but they all sort of coalesce into
seemingly the same place right two
different paths that lead us to the same
location
maybe that's exactly what's going on
with this whole thing i know there's a
desire especially on my behalf
to kind of link all this stuff together
because the marvel cinematic universe is
based off that captain america's shield
of hearing in iron man
thor's hammer showing up in new mexico
all these little bitty easter eggs that
we've seen over the course of the mcu
especially with their movies that kind
of tie them all together
so everything comes together in a more
uniform way when we get the avengers
film
i don't know if that's really what's
going on here in the tv show it'd be
kind of cool if it did
but regardless but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
and let me know your theories i would
love to hear those
uh if i end up doing a video on one i
will certainly give you credit
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace